this disconnect between the public's
view of copyright and fair use and on
what should and should not be prosecuted
versus the copyright Maximus view of the
law is our generations prohibition
copyright exists to promote the useful
arts according to the Constitution but
is it still doing that and should the
government protect so-called
intellectual property in the same way
that it protects other forms of property
we asked the professor a movie studio
representative and a tech company
founder and CEO these questions but
before we share their answers I want to
assure the MPAA officials watching this
video that I did my best not to use any
copyrighted material without the owner's
permission but it was pretty difficult
like it would be nice to use a clip from
Steamboat Willie Disney's first animated
feature when introducing this clip of
Chaplin the University professor Tom
Bell who invented a non copyrighted
graph called the Mickey Mouse curve
which we'll talk about later there are a
lot of people who equate copyright to
property and although there are
similarities I think that's a mistake
as soon as we start using the word
property for copyright we end up taking
less seriously our property rights and
things like cars and houses but some
people think copyright is the same as
property the Motion Picture Association
of America put out that famous ad which
we can't play here because it might be a
copyright violation that says you
wouldn't steal a car downloading pirated
films is stealing I think there is a
moral equivalence between you know
actual shoplifting of a physical object
as opposed to you know downloading say a
movie you know without paying for it
when you steal a candy bar or a car
you've left somebody without something
to eat or something to drive if you make
an unauthorized copy of a movie it may
be illegal maybe it should be illegal
but it's not theft not in the same way
that stealing property is theft because
why because the studio still has their
movie they don't make as much money as
they want but they still have not
suffered theft we can get into semantics
debates about whether or not one
qualifies as quote-unquote stealing or
not but the fact is that it's wrong
and it hurts creators and ultimately it
hurts the public because if this kind of
piracy is allowed to run rampant
it'll deprive the public of the next
great film the heated battle over the
Stop Online Piracy Act SOPA represents
the most recent clash over the proper
scope of copyright after a massive
online revolt led by tech giants like
Wikipedia and Google Congress took
notice and killed SOPA and it's Senate
counterpart PIPA I think that we had a
very close call I think SOPA and PIPA
almost went by on the undetected and
that would have been pretty damaging to
the Internet Ben ha is the founder and
CEO of cheeseburger home of Lal cats
failblog
and other internet favorites that were
the subject of what became the anti-sopa
movements protest song every login was
refused the day
the law cats died the more you read the
bill the more alarming it became every
single provision was like I can't
believe that writing this our web needs
more than lawyers lobbies and lives to
speak up before the internet dies but
chef nurse says that worries about sopas
reach were overblown these were narrowly
targeted bills at a specific kind of
foreign what we call rogue websites
these are basically websites that do
nothing else except distribute
infringing material but sites like
Google Wikipedia and cheeseburger
protested the bill because they feared
unintended consequences that might
result from the broad language in the
bills text we actually have an Austrian
domain name and in fact according to the
bill that would be considered a foreign
foreign site and if that site posted
material that was potentially infringing
a copyright in their view they would not
require a verdict from a court of law in
order to go pursue that domain so we as
a US company would fall under the
jurisdiction of this bill this is one in
a long long string of what we call
copyright Maxim ISM and in fact when you
look at copyrights in a Maximus view
almost everything we do is copyright
infringement
how did copyright law become so
far-reaching Tom Bell's Mickey Mouse
curve helps explain in 1928 Mickey Mouse
whom we cannot portray here in any
fashion so just try to imagine how these
three concentric black circles might
form his Vistage first onto the scene
was a movie called Steamboat Willie
which we also can't play here in the
following years Mickey Mouse became a
star and in fact the face of the giant
powerful beloved corporation which
presented a problem when to then 56-year
copyright term on Steamboat Willie was
approaching expiration but Congress
signed a 1976 copyright extension Act
which kicked in all to coincidentally
just in time to save Mickey from the
creative clutches of his would beat
filers for another 19 years
Mickey's time was running out once again
when the Sonny Bono acts saved the day
by extending the copyright life of works
of corporate authorship to a remarkable
120 years Mickey remains in safely white
gloved hands and
till at least 2023 the world's first
copyright law protected works for only
14 years if the copyright was 14 years
you would see Star Wars in the public
domain imagine the amount of creativity
imagine the amount of new business and
new content and new jobs that would
create but chef nurse says that it's the
strong enforcement of copyright that is
spurring creativity in jobs the damage
that piracy does is very deep and if
left unchecked it'll really have an
impact on the number and quality of
movies and television shows produced is
there a market failure in the production
and dissemination of expressive works if
we see a real deficiency in that area
boy we better take action but I don't
think we see that I don't think there's
any risk that we're gonna run out of
songs or books or movies or software any
time soon
while the MPAA and other entertainment
industry trade groups have been owned
the effects of rampant internet piracy
on creative output the numbers tell a
different story
research shows more music and books
produced than ever before between 2005
to 2010 production of feature films
growing by a factor of more than four in
14 years and the number of videogame
companies exploding by a factor of 18 in
the span of three years pus as the
MPAA's focus on piracy is nothing more
than a distraction the actual thing that
is killing the MPAA in DRA and the other
people is the lack of alternatives for
good people like you and me to get their
content in a way that they need I have
to shut myself out of my house out of my
PJs waste gas and then sit in a movie
theater with a bunch of people who I
don't know we're chewing and talking to
their phones why can't you let me see
first-run movies at home I'll pay you
for it of course the studios and other
copyright owners are adapt I mean
there's all sorts of new distribution
models that they're trying out every day
the thing that we try to make sure to do
is to MIT is to ensure that that that
the marketplace around the Internet is
governed by the rule of law and property
rights the MPAA's model for rule of law
of the Internet as their chairman Chris
Dodd said when the Chinese told Google
they had to block sites or they couldn't
do business in their country they
managed to figure out how to block sites
in certain circumstances we absolutely
believe that site blocking is an
appropriate remedy this has gone on in
many countries all over the world not
just in China but in for example in the
EU if site blocking broke the internet
the internet would have been broken a
long time ago if you give the United
States government basically a kill
switch to the internet premise taun
protecting copyrights what guarantee do
you have that they're gonna limit it to
only the worst infractions of copyrights
I'm afraid I don't trust our government
that far as the MPAA and other trade
organizations continue to push for more
government action to curb copyright
infringement
benoit believes that the fight is only
just beginning this disconnect between
the public's view of copyright and fair
use and what shouldn't should not be
prosecuted versus the copyright maximus
view of the law is our generations
prohibition the law no longer reflects
what the society believes to be true and
I think that if they continue to go down
that route they're gonna see even bigger
backlash and that's not you know
something that I came up with that's the
what American history tells us
why why Eliza think you could buy they
got pinup should be later free election
tonight our web means more than lawyers
lobbies of lies to speak up for the
Internet